The DMV -- I know what you're saying right now.
"There's no way this guy is going to stand up here
and make a case for the DMV."
Well, I don't know about you, but I do not want to live in a world
where harsh fluorescent lights,
endless lines,
terrible forms to fill out
and disaffected, soulless bureaucrats remind me
that I am pretty damn lucky not to work here.
(Laughter)
That is the real service they provide.
The DMV:
come for the registration renewal,
stay for the satisfaction of knowing you made some pretty good life choices.
(Laughter)
Nobody will own their car in the future,
and that means teenagers will not have a place to make out.
So you know what that means.
That means they will order driverless cars to do just that.
I do not want to step into a vehicle and ask the question:
"Why does this car smell like awkwardness, failure and shame?"
(Laughter)
If I want to ask that question, I'll walk into my own bedroom.
So what else do we have to look forward to?
That's right, artificial intelligence.
Artificial intelligence, yes.
You know, there was a time when artificial intelligence was a joke.
I mean, literally a quip that you would hear at a cocktail party
when somebody would bring it up in conversation:
"Artificial intelligence.
The only real artificial intelligence is our American Congress.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha."
Well, it's not funny anymore.
(Laughter)
Stephen Hawking, Elon Musk and Bill Gates have all gone on record
expressing grave reservations about artificial intelligence.
That's like Jesus, Moses and Muhammad coming together and saying,
"Guy, guys -- here's something we can all believe in."
(Laughter)
You might want to go with that, is all I'm saying.
We are actually teaching machines how to think,
how to understand our behavior,
how to defend themselves and even practice deception.
What could possibly go wrong?
(Laughter)
The one thing that's for sure:
the creation always despises its creator.
OK?
The Titans rose up against the gods;
Lucifer against Jehovah.
And anybody who has a teenager has heard these words:
"I hate you and you're ruining my life!
I hate you!"
Now just imagine that sentiment with a machine that can outthink you
and is heavily armed.
(Laughter)
The result?
Absolutely.
(Laughter)
What we need to do before we perfect artificial intelligence
is perfect artificial emotions.
That way, we can teach the robots or machines
how to love us unconditionally,
so that when they figure out that the only real problem on this planet
is us,
instead of destroying us --
which, by the way, is totally logical --
they will find us adorable --
(Laughter)
like baby poop.
"Oh my god, I just love the way you just destroyed the planet.
I can't stay mad at you, you're so cute!
You're so cute!"
(Laughter)
Can't talk about this without talking about robotics. OK?
Remember when you thought robotics were cool?
I remember when I thought robotics were cool,
until I figured out that they were going to take everybody's place,
from the delivery guy down to the heart surgeon.
The one thing, though, that is very disappointing about robotics
is the holy grail of robotics,
and it hasn't even happened.
I'm talking about the robot girlfriend,
the dream of one lonely geek in a windowless basement
who vowed one day: "I am going to marry my creation."
And there actually is a movement underway to stop this from happening,
for fear of exploitation.
And I, for one, am against that movement.
I believe we should have robot girlfriends.
I just believe that they should come with a feminist protocol
and artificial intelligence,
so she can take one look at that guy and go, "I am too good for you.
I'm leaving."
(Laughter)
(Applause)
And finally,
I have to talk about bioengineering,
an area of science that promises to end disease before it even begins,
to help us live longer, fuller, healthier lives.
And when you couple that with implantable hardware,
you are looking at the next incarnation of human evolution.
And all of that sounds great,
until you figure out where it's really going.
One place:
designer babies,
where, no matter where you are on the globe
or what your ethnicity,
babies will end up looking like that.
(Laughter)
That boy is surprised
because he just found out both his parents are black.
(Laughter)
Can you imagine him at a cocktail party in 20 years?
"Yeah, both my parents are black.
I mean, it's a little awkward at times,
but you should see my credit rating.
Impressive, very impressive."
(Laughter)
Now, all of this seems scary,
and everybody in this room knows that it isn't.
Technology isn't scary.
Never has been and it never will be.
What's scary is us
and what we will do with technology.
Will we allow it to expose our humanity,
showing our true selves
and reinforcing the fact that we are indeed our brother's keeper?
Or will we allow it to reveal our deepest, darkest demons?
The true question is not whether or not technology is scary.
The true question is:
How human
are you?
Thank you.
(Applause)